you jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money Katie is with us in San
Diego hi Katie how are you hi Dave I'm
good how are you better than I deserve
what's up well I'm just trying to get
some advice on how to get my husband on
the same page with our budget he's kind
of more like since when don't have any
debt and he works really hard he's in
the Navy so he's kind of like I work
hard I don't really want to be on a
budget yeah yeah call the wambulance I
work hard oh and I'm kinda like I don't
care we're sticking to this budget yeah
okay chuckling look I don't care if you
work hard or not you're not a little boy
you're man okay and I'm married to a guy
that I need to be a man and a man
actually is mature and plans into the
future with his wife and so a budget is
you and I sitting down together and
telling our money what to do instead of
just working our whole life and then
being freaking broke right okay that's
all it is I mean you know just call him
out on his manhood he's in the Navy come
on right and I and I kind of did calm
out but he's just like well I just feel
like we're not laying well you work for
it so you want to end up with nothing
and you want your wife to make all the
decisions I don't want to be your mother
darling I want to be your wife exactly I
feel like his mom sometimes only a
dadgum right because he's when work you
hard I should be really bad whatever I
want
what are you in Congress I mean
seriously this is ridiculous it's just
me it's absurd he's just being a he's
being he's being childish and you need
to call him out on that I mean you could
do it you can do it with humor you can
do it smart aleck or you can be real
caustic like I'm being which might not
be as effective actually but but I'm
trying to communicate to you that you're
exactly right and he's out of line okay
and so you need to do you need leaning
on this how old are you guys I'm 29 he's
30 okay it's time to grow up yeah
angry yeah you're a real boy now
Pinocchio so let's get on with it
you know 430 years old let's uh let's be
something right hey listen a budget does
not mean he can't do anything after he
works hard I worked my butt off I want
to buy some stuff I go along with him on
that but I'm not going to be here
responsible and have my wife make all
the decisions by herself and carry all
the weight of the household finances by
herself because I just don't want to
deal with because I work hard right that
mean angry now you're he's probably
never gonna be a budget nerd right no
absolutely not and I don't want him to
be I'm not asking him to be that I'm
just asking look at the situation with
you and agree to our family's goals and
what our family is going to do and that
includes his vote he gets a vote on this
right right so I do the budget at our
house I'm the math nerd at our house and
you know Sharon and I make the decisions
together and then we both stick to them
and then I do the actual implementation
okay all right all right thank you thank
you thanks for the call open phones a
triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5 let me tell you
that is I pick on guys on that kind of
stuff pretty hard but it depends kind of
how you grew up if you grew up and in
your household your dad brought home the
bacon and your mama fried it meaning
your mama did all the bills and your dad
just worked he brought home handed mom a
check and then he went and sat in the
recliner and she took care of the
household she run the household then
when you get married it's your tendency
to do that and you know that happens in
highly educated families in blue-collar
families in rural families and urban
families it's there's no trend in that
it's just how you grew up and you
watched your family do it but what we
know from having done this stuff this
money stuff for 30 years is the number
one cause of arguments in marriage is
about money and the number one cause of
divorce in North America money fights
money problems and stresses and and add
to that and this is not as much done in
turn to that conversation they're quite
as much but it can add to that that
we've got a
group of young people coming on that are
emotionally maturing much later in life
than ever before in generational we know
that because 29 percent of the males
under the age of 30 are still living
with their parents if that doesn't make
you want to throw up something should
that's a dangerous oshi illogical danger
to our culture it's called the whistle
fication of America mama's boy
needs to get out of the basement and if
you take that guy and you marry him and
his only skill set is Nintendo and you
marry him off then he ends up with his
wife being his mother because he never
assumed emotional maturity of a man to
be able to walk alongside a woman same
thing to go for a girl if a little girl
stays at home and she's daddy's little
princess and I'm staying here because I
saved money but I refuse to go out in
the real freaking world pay my own light
bill ever and I'm 29 years old or I'm 39
years old I still live at home unless
you're going unless you've gone back
home for a healing because you've been
through a bad situation but not if
you're just sitting there just not
emotionally developing not maturing then
you know then pity the man that marries
this princess because now he's got to be
daddy instead of husband there's a
different role you play in a
relationship and so if that's you and
I'm picking on you good I'm trying to
pick on you for your own good I want to
wake you up some of the best things that
have caused me to change my life more
than anything else is when somebody made
me mad so one of my gifts here is I make
some of you mad good because it'll get
you off of your butt and on to the next
level of your life and so if you're
married and your dad always handed the
check over to your mom you ought to ask
your wife when you get home if you
handing the check over to her is a
blessing because she probably doesn't
think it is she's probably tired of
carrying all the decision-making by
herself and having to run around behind
you with a pooper scooper because you're
making messes everywhere and she
the only grown-up in the house she's
probably pretty sick and tired of that
and you can change it from male to
female and it can go the other way you
know if you're a little lady at home and
you know my wife used to say whatever
you undo honey where you want to do
honey
translation if you do it wrong I'm gonna
kill you later but I'm gonna try I'm
gonna let you do whatever you want to no
that doesn't work
we don't do that stuff no no we know I
don't do whatever you want to do honey I
don't do that I mean if it's a minor
little thing sure if she's asked I'm
saying hey I'm gonna go have a cup of
coffee with buddy in mind tonight and
he's and she says whatever you are doing
yeah I'll do that that's not what I'm
talking about
I'm not henpecked but when we sit down
and are making our life decisions
together and it's a big decision and she
looks at me whatever you want to do know
what's your frickin opinion you get to
vote on this and by the way if it goes
bad we're gonna say we did this together
if it goes good we're gonna say we did
this together not I told you so I knew I
need you to mess that in you know I
don't wanna hear that crap later we
don't need that see that's how those
relationships break down around this
particular subject so it's a really good
question the young lady asks and you
know it addresses the whole would
suffocate of America thing is part of
the deal this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right it's
kind of better than
save room to channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget one of the best videos out there
you